Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我和我的商业导师Lisa Johnson共同举办的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢得与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》。
Thank you for listening and thank you if you have previously listened to other episodes as well. We are nearing our 8,000th download in a little under six months. And it's all thanks to you, my very loyal listeners, or maybe even my brand new listeners who are finding this content really useful. I would love to know what your favorite episode is, and I would love for you to share it on socials and tag me in you can do that on your stories in Instagram by tagging in Dr. Marianne Trent you can do that on LinkedIn as well I am Dr. Marianne Trent you can do it on Facebook tag me in there as Good Thinking Psychological Services or if we're connected on Facebook you can tag me as Marianne Trent as well. Tag me in all those places that would also be wonderful but tell people why you like the episode
感谢你的收听，也感谢你之前收听过其他节目。在不到六个月的时间里，我们的下载量即将达到8000次。这一切都要归功于你们，我非常忠实的听众，或者可能是刚刚发现这些内容非常有用的新听众。我很想知道你最喜欢哪一期节目，也希望你能将其分享到社交媒体并标记我。你可以在Instagram的故事中标记Dr. Marianne Trent，也可以在LinkedIn上标记我（我是Dr. Marianne Trent），或者在Facebook上标记Good Thinking Psychological Services，如果你在Facebook上与我建立了联系，也可以标记Marianne Trent。在所有这些平台上标记我当然很好，但请告诉大家你为什么喜欢这期节目，
and why it resonates with you. Encourage others to listen too as it really helps me know that this content is useful and beneficial for you and that you are pleased to be in my world. What am I going to talk to you about today? Well, today I'm going to talk to you about my experiences of working in the National Health Service, both as an assistant psychologist, as a trainee psychologist and then as a qualified psychologist too. There is no real plan to this episode. It is going to be a case of, you know, winding her up and watching her go, see where I go. But I hope you'll find it useful because I know for many people who are striving to progress their career in psychology it feels like you know working for the NHS certainly if you want to
以及它为什么能引起你的共鸣。鼓励其他人也来收听，因为这真的能让我知道这些内容对你们是有用且有益的，也让我知道你们很高兴能进入我的世界。今天我要和大家聊些什么呢？嗯，今天我要谈谈我在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）工作的经历，包括作为助理心理学家、实习心理学家以及后来成为合格心理学家的过程。这期节目没有具体的计划，我会随性而谈，看看会聊到哪里。但我希望你会觉得它有用，因为我知道对于许多努力在心理学领域发展职业生涯的人来说，如果你想
get onto clinical training and be funded by the NHS to train it feels like acquiring some NHS experience prior to commencing your training is going to be beneficial for you. With that, I would say it's not always necessary. So you know that I, if you've been in my world a while, you'll know anyway that I previously worked at St Andrews Healthcare. And actually, there are people I worked with there who got on to professional doctorate courses having only ever worked in St Andrews but usually under the supervision of a qualified psychologist so for me I think it is more about the quality of your supervision and the type of work that you're being asked to do that is psychologically informed and, you know, just absolutely on model for what you'd be doing really in your realm of professional psychology. So, yeah, I don't think it's so much the
进入临床培训并获得NHS的资助，那么在开始培训之前积累一些NHS的工作经验似乎是有益的。话虽如此，我认为这并不总是必要的。如果你关注我一段时间了，你就会知道我之前曾在圣安德鲁斯医疗保健中心（St Andrews Healthcare）工作过。事实上，我的一些同事只在圣安德鲁斯工作过，但也成功进入了专业博士课程，不过他们通常是在合格心理学家的监督下工作的。所以对我来说，我认为更重要的是你所受监督的质量，以及你被要求从事的工作类型是否具有心理学依据，并且是否符合你在专业心理学领域真正要做的事情。所以，是的，我不认为这主要取决于
organisation, although, of course, the ability to work with MDTs and large teams and, you know, to hold caseloads and work with a variety of clients and professionals too is advantageous. And that is something that the NHS does afford you. So I did work for local government before I started working for St Andrews. And, you know, I think working for any large organisation that's well established and has lots of policies and procedures and, you know, where things don't happen overnight can be really good experience for boosting your your own CV and your skills and your talents, but also for knowing how large organizations work. So similarly, St. Andrews was a large hospital and it's since expanded to have other locations as well and so you know that is yeah it is a large organization and they do work differently than smaller ones so my own organization good thinking psychological services is very small comparatively and so I can do things in a really adaptive and if needs to be reactive way in the way that I found to be
机构，尽管能够与多学科团队（MDT）合作、在大型团队中工作、处理病例并与各种客户和专业人士打交道确实是有优势的。而这正是NHS能为你提供的。在我开始在圣安德鲁斯工作之前，我曾在地方政府工作过。我认为，在任何大型、成熟且拥有完善政策和程序的机构工作，并且事情不会在一夜之间发生变化，对于提升你的简历、技能和才华，以及了解大型机构的运作方式都是非常好的经验。同样，圣安德鲁斯也是一家大型医院，后来也扩展到了其他地点，所以它确实是一家大型机构，他们的运作方式与小型机构不同。相比之下，我自己的机构“Good Thinking Psychological Services”非常小，所以我可以以一种非常灵活的方式行事，如果需要的话，可以做出即时反应，而我在NHS工作后期发现，在那种环境下是无法做到这一点的。
quite frustrating that you couldn't do in the NHS towards the end of my time there. You know I can come up with different techniques and approaches and roll with them the same day if I want to and you just can't do that in the NHS, and that is frustrating to someone who wants to innovate and can see ways for changing and, you know, for clients to have better experiences. But this is a whole separate debate. So my first experience of working for the NHS was when I was an assistant psychologist and the way that the funding pots work means that it was a slightly different employing sort of base than where I was actually working because it's kind of divvied up so I was working for what was Milton Keynes Hospital
你知道，我可以想出不同的技巧和方法，如果我想的话，当天就可以实施，但在NHS你根本做不到。对于一个想要创新、能看到改变方式并希望客户获得更好体验的人来说，这确实令人沮丧。但这又是另一个话题了。我第一次在NHS工作的经历是担任助理心理学家，由于资金分配方式的原因，我的雇佣基础与我实际工作的地方略有不同，因为它是分摊的。所以我当时是为米尔顿凯恩斯医院（Milton Keynes Hospital）工作，
but I actually wasn't working on the Milton Keynes hospital site I was working nearby at a youth prison so at that point it was quite novel for the health care systems to be operated by the NHS but certainly that one was and so it was a really nice opportunity to get an NHS funded assistant post. But I was working under the qualified direction of a qualified forensic psychologist, but I was very clear that my job title was assistant clinical psychologist. So I was doing clinical work and not stuff necessarily indicated with the young person's index offence. More about their wellbeing and their, you know, I guess their relationship to trauma as well, which of course is indicated often with the index offence. But
但我实际上并没有在米尔顿凯恩斯医院的院区工作，而是在附近的一所青少年监狱工作。在当时，由NHS运营医疗保健系统是相当新颖的，但那所监狱确实是由NHS运营的，所以这是一个获得NHS资助的助理职位的绝佳机会。我是在一位合格的法医心理学家的指导下工作的，但我很清楚我的职位名称是助理临床心理学家。所以我做的是临床工作，而不一定与年轻人的犯罪记录相关。更多的是关于他们的福祉，以及，我想，他们与创伤的关系，当然，这通常与犯罪记录有关。但是，
similarly to a previous episode where I've mentioned the wonderful QC, Chris Dawes' book Justice on Trial, you know, there's a lot of trauma within justice systems, both adult and young people. So I actually only worked for the NHS for six months. So I started in February and I left in August to go off travelling because I got a place on the doctorate scheme and I just you know got all footloose and fancy free and went off and had a really lovely time with another friend who was actually going to be starting her own clinical doctorate course as well so yeah if you are listening to this because you are going to shortly be starting as a trainee psychologist, then is there any possibility that you could have a bit
就像我在之前的一期节目中提到的，优秀的御用大律师Chris Dawes的书《审判中的正义》（Justice on Trial）一样，司法系统中存在大量的创伤，无论是成人还是年轻人。我实际上只在NHS工作了六个月。我二月份开始工作，八月份就辞职去旅行了，因为我获得了博士项目的名额，我变得无拘无束，和另一位朋友度过了一段非常美好的时光，她当时也要开始自己的临床博士课程了。所以，是的，如果你正在收听这期节目，因为你很快就要开始作为实习心理学家的生涯，那么你是否有可能在人生的这些重要篇章之间留出一点
of time off between these important chapters of your life where you don't necessarily need to be thinking about what this gap looks like on your CV and what you might be missing out on it's more of a chance of how can you replenish yourself how can you reward yourself for this time that you've really spent focusing on a really you know really important destination so yeah again it's a bit of another aside, isn't it? You never know where I might end up. But, you know, if you are going to be applying for clinical training next year, or any type of professional psychology training, if you do learn in spring or summer, that you have been successful, then how could you free yourself up to imagine that you might spend
时间休息呢？你不必非要考虑这段空白在简历上看起来如何，或者你可能会错过什么。这更多是一个机会，让你思考如何补充能量，如何奖励自己，因为你确实花了很多时间专注于一个非常重要的目标。所以，是的，这又是一个题外话，不是吗？你永远不知道我会聊到哪里。但是，如果你明年要申请临床培训，或者任何类型的专业心理学培训，如果你在春季或夏季得知自己成功了，那么你如何让自己腾出时间来想象一下你可能会如何度过
some of that time? You know, you could dream big, you know, you could dream a little round the world trip. Obviously, this is finances depending, but also dependence depending as well. So if you are a parent or you've got people that you care for that might be that might feel slightly more aspirational but you know are the things that you would like to do to help you celebrate that phase in your life could you I don't know book yourself a few spa treatments or beauty treatments or go and stay with friends in a different part of the country or go and you know have a couple of days in an Airbnb somewhere nice and by the sea to really just recharge yourself and to celebrate you and your well-done-ness but I feel like this is a whole separate episode
那段时间呢？你可以大胆梦想，比如来一次环球旅行。当然，这取决于经济状况，也取决于是否有家庭负担。所以如果你是父母，或者有需要照顾的人，这可能会感觉更具抱负。但有没有什么事情是你愿意做的，来帮助你庆祝人生的那个阶段？比如，预订一些水疗或美容护理，或者去国内其他地方的朋友家住几天，或者在海边找个不错的Airbnb住上几天，真正地让自己充电，庆祝你的成就。但我感觉这又是另一期节目了，
that probably needs to be recorded doesn't it so. So I worked there for six months and then I went off travelling. Yeah, that's why I got distracted, because that sounded more exciting than working for the NHS. And it was. But yeah, I did take a lot of value from my fellow nursing colleagues and my forensic psychology supervisor. It was quite a small organisation to work for, quite a small base I should say that I was working for and that was very different than having worked for a large
可能需要专门录制一期，对吧？所以我工作了六个月，然后就去旅行了。是的，我之所以分心，是因为那听起来比在NHS工作更令人兴奋。确实如此。但我确实从我的护理同事和法医心理学主管那里学到了很多价值。那是一个规模很小的机构，我应该说我工作的基地很小，这与在一家拥有许多不同部门的大型
hospital with many different divisions. So you know just having to get used to a little bit more of, yeah, just a smaller way of, yeah, just thinking and operating. You might just have heard that little ping from my emails that meant I forgot to I forgot to shut my emails down before I filmed. So, yeah, I'm sorry about that. I will try and edit it out if I can but it might well just stick around so training for me because I was a trainee clinical psychologist was three years of being employed by the NHS at band six and for me going from band four to band six that was quite a nice pay rise at the time. So working for the NHS meant that you obviously have to be an employee for them and adhere to their trust values and you know their their principles and their protocols and their procedures and you need to be you know a good
医院工作非常不同。所以，习惯于一种更小规模的思考和运作方式。你可能刚刚听到了我邮件的提示音，这意味着我忘记在录制前关闭邮件提醒了。所以，对此我很抱歉。我会尽量剪掉它，但它可能还是会留在里面。对我来说，因为我是一名实习临床心理学家，所以我在NHS以六级（Band 6）身份工作了三年。对我来说，从四级升到六级在当时是一次相当不错的加薪。在NHS工作意味着你显然必须成为他们的员工，遵守他们的信托价值观、原则、协议和程序，你需要成为一名优秀的
employee you need to be thinking about you know where possible trying to keep your sick leave absence as little as possible because they're going to be looking at your attendance and you know the same is true even with when you are a trainee psychologist if you are being employed that they have to make sure that you are well enough to be in your role and that you are you know creating good value for the NHS because there's work that you need to be doing you know know, the core work. So they want you to be seeing clients on placement and ideally helping those clients to move towards their goals, but also helping the service move towards its goals as well.
员工。你需要考虑在可能的情况下尽量减少病假，因为他们会关注你的出勤率。即使当你是一名实习心理学家时，如果你是被雇佣的，他们也必须确保你的身体状况足以胜任你的角色，并且你正在为NHS创造良好的价值，因为你需要完成核心工作。所以他们希望你在实习期间接触客户，理想情况下帮助这些客户实现他们的目标，同时也帮助服务部门实现其目标。
There's, you know, there's a lot of, a lot of balls to juggle when you are, um, a trainee psychologist. Um, you know, you've got to juggle the responsibilities for your own line management. really crossed paths other than him signing off on my expenses every month for driving about here there and everywhere and parking costs and things but yeah I don't think I ever had to see him for anything else at all during my three years and I think even during those three years I think the original chap retired and then someone else came along and I don't think I met him in a managerial capacity as well but during training you will usually have placements certainly if you're doing clinical psychology you will have placements but those placements might not all be NHS. You might have a specialist placement for example that is outside of an NHS service
当你是一名实习心理学家时，有很多事情需要兼顾。你需要处理好自己的直线管理责任。除了他每个月为我开车到处跑、停车费等报销单签字外，我们几乎没有交集。但我认为在三年的时间里，我不需要因为任何其他事情见到他。我想即使在那三年里，最初的那位主管退休了，然后换了别人，我也不认为我在管理层面上见过他。但在培训期间，你通常会有实习机会，当然如果你在做临床心理学，你会有实习，但这些实习可能并不都在NHS。例如，你可能会有一个在NHS服务之外的专业实习，
and so you'll have a supervisor who is not an NHS member of staff in that in that set of circumstances in the most part so certainly all six of my supervisors were NHS supervisors but of course my course team were not NHS staff they were academic staff at the university and so you're juggling a lot of different you know requests and responsibilities and professional procedures, really. And that could just take a little bit of kind of figuring out and that can just take a little bit of figuring out really as you adjust to that. So this feels like it's an episode on gearing you up for, you know, professional qualification as well um you know it is many things to many people at this point we're just going to take a short break
在这种情况下，你的主管大部分时间都不是NHS的员工。当然，我的六位主管都是NHS的主管，但我的课程团队当然不是NHS员工，他们是大学的学术人员。所以你实际上是在处理许多不同的要求、责任和专业程序。这可能需要一点时间来摸索，当你适应这一切时，确实需要一点时间来理清头绪。所以这感觉像是一期为你准备专业资格认证的节目，它在这一点上对许多人来说意味着很多。我们现在要休息一下，
and I'll be back very soon If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective is a fantastic read for aspiring clinical psychologists. This book provides insights from real trainees and qualified psychologists. They offer their advice, hope and encouragement to aspiring clinical psychologists.
很快就会回来。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。书中充满了将帮助你获得资格的课程和经验。所以来看看吧，就在这本书里。这就是《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。《临床心理学家集体》对于有抱负的临床心理学家来说是一本非常棒的读物。这本书提供了来自真实实习生和合格心理学家的见解。他们为有抱负的临床心理学家提供了建议、希望和鼓励。
This book helps to put in perspective the variety of journeys people take to become qualified. I would recommend this book to anyone interested in the D-Clinci. Be your guide Filled with lessons and experience That will help you get qualified So come and take a look It's right here in this book It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Boom. Okay, so one of the things I liked about working for the NHS was that it was such a big organisation.
这本书有助于从不同角度看待人们获得资格的各种旅程。我会向任何对临床心理学博士（D-ClinPsy）感兴趣的人推荐这本书。让它成为你的指南，书中充满了将帮助你获得资格的课程和经验。所以来看看吧，就在这本书里。这就是《临床心理学家集体》。这就是《临床心理学家集体》。砰。好了，我喜欢在NHS工作的一点是，它是一个如此庞大的组织。
And you could usually find someone who knew the answer to your question, or who had already tried to do the thing that you were doing. So you could kind of network and liaise with them. Sometimes that could be a little bit of a sticking point, because you know, people want to follow, you know, what's gone before it it but if there's been a million unnecessary steps that go before it that can feel a little bit frustrating but you know there's plenty of opportunity for carrying out research within the NHS as well because it's probably highly likely that your trust has a research department or research lead and so with your line management or supervisory approval you can often make contact with them to see if there's any research that you might be able
你通常可以找到知道你问题答案的人，或者已经尝试过你正在做的事情的人。所以你可以与他们建立联系并进行沟通。有时这可能是一个症结所在，因为人们想要遵循前人的做法，但如果前人有数百万个不必要的步骤，这可能会让人感到有点沮丧。但NHS内部也有很多进行研究的机会，因为你的信托机构很可能有研究部门或研究负责人，所以经过直线管理或主管批准，你通常可以与他们联系，看看是否有你可以提供支持的研究。
to to help support with and of course because it would be a trust initiative, you might well be able to get that sorted out within your work time. So you'd be getting paid to do research or thinking about whether you could bring research to your service and be paid for it. So what is not to like there? One of the other things that I think makes it really nice about working for the NHS is that, you know, in my experience, certainly, people were largely working, you know, nine to five, which meant that there would usually be some sort of opportunity for sitting down with your colleagues and having lunch. Now, I was a big believer and still am a big believer in having lunch. I put it in my diary every day and always have done because certainly in the NHS, you don't get paid for that time, but you do have to take it.
当然，因为这将是一项信托倡议，你很可能可以在工作时间内完成。所以你是在拿工资做研究，或者思考是否可以将研究引入你的服务部门并获得报酬。那有什么不好的呢？我认为在NHS工作的另一个优点是，至少在我的经验中，人们大多是朝九晚五工作的，这意味着通常会有机会与同事坐下来吃午餐。我一直很相信吃午餐，现在依然如此。我每天都在日记里写下它，一直都是这样，因为在NHS，你虽然不拿那段时间的工资，但你必须休息。
And so I took it because because it was good for me. And because I need to eat, you know, I'm not the sort of person that can, you know, work on pasta, hungry, grumbling stomach. I, productivity plummets quite rapidly if I'm hungry. And my patience certainly dissipates too if I'm a bit hungry. So I always made time for lunch, but I had a very good impact on my colleagues as well because they would often try and come and join me for lunch. And when I was in, you know, when I was in a local service with some local shops, we'd instigate, you know, chippy lunch every now and then as well and that was very popular but yeah trying not to eat at your desk is key try and make sure that you do have a break because this is difficult work that you are doing as an aspiring psychologist and so
所以我休息了，因为这对我有好处。而且因为我需要吃饭，我不是那种可以饿着肚子、肚子咕咕叫还能工作的人。如果我饿了，工作效率会迅速下降。如果我饿了，我的耐心肯定也会消失。所以我总是留出时间吃午餐，这对我的同事也产生了很好的影响，因为他们经常会来和我一起吃午餐。当我在一个有当地商店的本地服务部门工作时，我们偶尔也会发起“炸鱼薯条午餐”，这非常受欢迎。但尽量不要在办公桌前吃饭是关键，尽量确保你确实有休息时间，因为作为一名有抱负的心理学家，你所做的工作很困难，所以
having some time to be mindful about something that is non-work focused, non-work related, will really help you to decompress and to come through these difficult times, you know, with, you know, more, with better well-being, I hope. And, you know, within the NHS, I had a lovely time connecting with, you know, nursing colleagues. And one of my absolute favourite things about working for the NHS is the people you meet along the way. And I was talking to one of my friend's mums just yesterday. Hi, Angela. Name check her there um and talking about um the wonderful people that you do meet in um in mental health but also physical health because you're meeting people who are fellow nurturers and they really can help shape you and look after you and look out for you and I know that my um my friend and ex-co now, Jane, wouldn't mind me name checking her. But I was really pleased to have met her along my journey into, well, that was when I was a qualified member of staff.
留出一些时间来关注非工作相关的事情，真的会帮助你减压，并希望你能以更好的状态度过这些困难时期。在NHS，我和护理同事们度过了一段美好的时光。我最喜欢在NHS工作的一点就是你一路上遇到的人。昨天我还在和一位朋友的妈妈聊天，向Angela问好，谈论你在心理健康领域，以及身体健康领域遇到的那些了不起的人，因为你遇到的是同样具有培育精神的人，他们真的可以帮助塑造你、照顾你并关照你。我知道我的朋友兼前同事Jane不会介意我提到她的名字。但我很高兴在我的旅程中遇到了她，那是在我成为合格员工的时候。
But you can never meet enough good people who warm your soul and who get you and you know that's one of my favorite things about working in this industry of ours is the people that you meet along the way and those that you choose to keep along the way as well you know you can snap snap them off from whatever job that you're working in and you know mentally take them with you sometimes even physically take them with you, sometimes even physically take them with you, but you can still keep them in your world, either by getting together in person or connecting, you know, virtually via email or socials as well. And yeah, I've just had some wonderfully nurturing supervisors along the way as well. And I most definitely kept most of those in my life too so those are my top tips for surviving the NHS which sounds a bit bleak I know but you know make sure you're taking time for yourself and you know really seek to make connections with the people around you especially those that make you feel
但你永远无法遇到足够多温暖你灵魂、懂你的人。这是我最喜欢在这个行业工作的一点，就是你一路上遇到的人，以及你选择在这一路上保持联系的人。你可以从你工作的任何岗位中结识他们，在精神上带着他们，有时甚至在身体上带着他们，但你仍然可以让他们留在你的世界里，无论是通过亲自见面，还是通过电子邮件或社交媒体进行虚拟联系。是的，我一路上也遇到了一些非常具有培育精神的主管。我绝对把他们中的大多数也留在了我的生活中。所以这些是我在NHS生存的秘诀，我知道这听起来有点凄凉，但请确保你为自己留出时间，并真正寻求与周围的人建立联系，尤其是那些让你感觉良好的人。
good I always when joining a team would shadow other members of the team. And when people joined the team, I would have them shadow me, even if they weren't working in psychology. And I know that even recently, an occupational therapist I'd previously worked with had said that she still found that session that she did with me incredibly fascinating and that she thought about it really often so you never know where the impact what you might have from the people that you work with so I did work in the NHS once I qualified I worked in a children and adolescent mental health service for almost four years. And I had a baby during that time as well. I got married during that time.
我每次加入一个团队时，都会跟随其他团队成员工作。当有人加入团队时，我会让他们跟随我，即使他们不是从事心理学工作的。我知道即使是最近，我之前合作过的一位职业治疗师也说，她仍然觉得那次和我一起的会议非常迷人，她经常想起它。所以你永远不知道你对一起工作的人会有什么影响。我确实在获得资格后在NHS工作过，我在一个儿童和青少年心理健康服务部门工作了近四年。那段时间我还生了一个孩子。我结婚了。
And then I continued to work for the NHS. And I had another baby in my second qualified role in adult mental health. So, yeah, I did make the decision to leave the NHS, but that was only after I'd tried to negotiate dropping down to less days so that I could focus more on private work. But we couldn't make that work. It wasn't agreed. And over time, I just thought, you know what, I think I might want to leave which felt really challenging it felt um yeah really scary but also felt really exciting um and I'd already been working in a private capacity for a little while um by the time I went by the time I went fully fledged private um so I think it was probably getting on for about 18 months by the time I left and so I knew I could potentially make it work and I haven't looked back but that said I do miss working
然后我继续为NHS工作。我在第二个合格职位——成人心理健康部门工作时又生了一个孩子。所以，是的，我确实做出了离开NHS的决定，但那是在我尝试协商减少工作天数以便专注于私人工作之后。但我们没能达成一致。随着时间的推移，我只是想，你知道吗，我想我可能想离开。这感觉非常有挑战性，感觉非常可怕，但也感觉非常令人兴奋。在我完全转为私人执业时，我已经以私人身份工作了一段时间了，所以我想在我离开时，这大概已经持续了18个月左右，所以我知道我可能能做到，而且我从未后悔。但话虽如此，我确实怀念与团队一起工作，
with my team and I miss probably the more informal chances that you have to get together with people. You know, I don't miss meetings, but I probably miss the beginning and the ends of meetings where things became, you know, they were just, you know, warming up and checking in with each other. And, you know, just making sure that everyone's OK and, you know, a little bit of, you know, water cooler chat and humour and, you know, all of that. You know, what did you watch on TV last night or did you see Britain's Got Talent? Yes, I did. You know, that's all part of being a team as well. And I know that when my children were homeschooled during the pandemic, I was, you know, quite surprised how little work they were doing. You know, I'd imagined, perhaps naively, that when my children were at school, that they were doing, you know, six hours of education, apart from their lunch break and their play breaks. But it really wasn't. It was very much more low key than that. You know, it's probably only about two solid hours of work.
也怀念那些与人聚在一起的非正式机会。我不怀念会议，但我可能怀念会议开始和结束时，大家热身、互相问候、确保每个人都还好，以及在饮水机旁聊天、开玩笑的时候。比如，你昨晚看了什么电视，或者你看了《英国达人秀》吗？是的，我看了。这也是团队的一部分。我知道当我的孩子们在疫情期间在家上学时，我非常惊讶他们做的工作竟然那么少。我曾天真地想象，当我的孩子们在学校时，除了午餐和课间休息，他们是在进行六个小时的教育。但事实并非如此。它比那要低调得多。可能只有大约两个小时的专注工作。
Maybe even if that the rest is, I don't know, I guess, consolidation and, you know, discussion. But actual focused work was very different than my own experiences of being at school. And, you know, I think when we look at the way that people are working, not to quote Boris and the cheese, but the actual hard work that we're doing on any given day, when we look at that in hours is, you know, it's a little bit different with us, because if we're doing client sessions, then of course, you've got those client hours, but you've also got the admin that goes with that. But if you're in an admin role, you know, it might be that, you know, you're not working solidly seven and a half hours because there's kind of time built in your day for flex to be able to, you know, spend time with colleagues and, you know, to be able to make cups of tea and things. And I'm not disparaging in any way the way that you're working, but I couldn't say hand on hand that I work around the clock. And I've created my job to work, my business to work in the way that I want it to,
甚至可能更少，其余时间我想大概是巩固和讨论。但实际的专注工作与我在学校的经历非常不同。我认为当我们审视人们的工作方式时，不是引用鲍里斯和奶酪的例子，而是我们每天所做的实际艰苦工作，当我们按小时来看时，这与我们有点不同，因为如果我们进行客户会谈，那么你当然有那些客户时间，但你也有随之而来的行政工作。但如果你从事行政工作，你可能不会连续工作七个半小时，因为你的一天中内置了弹性时间，可以与同事共度时光，可以泡茶等等。我绝不是在贬低你的工作方式，但我不能拍着胸脯说我全天候工作。我已经创建了我的工作，我的业务，以我想要的方式运作，
so that I have now got time to be able to to go and do my personal training sessions in my work time because I recognize that it's so much more likely to happen if I do that whereas if I leave it to the evenings or the weekends it just ain't gonna happen and so yeah I think within large organisations like the NHS, they've obviously got standards to meet, they've got targets to meet, and you will probably, as an aspiring psychologist, find yourself having to be accountable to those standards and those targets. But there's not usually an expectation that you'll be working with your nose to the grindstone um you know for seven and a half hours a day but that said i know that many people who are certainly aspiring clinical psychologists are finding that the expectations of them for their face-to-face work um are great and that does lead to burnout you know um maybe there needs to be a bit more uh you know
所以我现在有时间在工作时间内去进行个人训练课程，因为我意识到如果我这样做，它发生的可能性要大得多，而如果我把它留到晚上或周末，它根本就不会发生。所以，是的，我认为在像NHS这样的大型组织中，他们显然有需要达到的标准，有需要达到的目标，作为一名有抱负的心理学家，你可能会发现自己必须对这些标准和目标负责。但通常不会期望你每天埋头苦干七个半小时。但话虽如此，我知道许多有抱负的临床心理学家发现，对他们面对面工作的期望很高，这确实会导致倦怠。也许需要更多一点
flex for human time and human connection time so i would love to know what you think to anything that i've spoken about today um i would love to know what your favorite episode of this aspiring psychologist podcast is. We have got the next batch of applicants in the aspiring psychologist membership coming up, opening on the 1st of July. So if you'd like to be on the waiting list, ready for when that opens, ready for us to guide you through this next application season then do check out the details in the show notes come on over and like and subscribe to the good thinking psychological services youtube channel won't you because you know good stuff happens on there and you can also listen to the podcast episodes there too. Have I got anything else to tell you? You can, of course,
为人类时间和人类联系时间留出弹性。所以我很想知道你对我今天所说的任何事情有什么看法。我很想知道你最喜欢《有抱负的心理学家播客》的哪一期。我们即将迎来下一批“有抱负的心理学家会员”，将于7月1日开放。所以如果你想进入等待名单，准备好迎接开放，准备好让我们引导你度过下一个申请季，那么请查看节目说明中的详细信息。过来点赞并订阅“Good Thinking Psychological Services”YouTube频道吧，因为那里有很多好东西，你也可以在那里收听播客节目。我还有什么要告诉你的吗？你当然可以
still check out information either to buy the Aspiring Psychologist collective book when it comes out, hopefully in October, or if you have got interesting stories to tell we are still accepting submissions and details of how you can make your submission are included in the show notes right thank you so very much for being part of my world and for listening and don't forget that if you've got any questions for me for this special Ask Marianne Anything session that is coming up on the podcast, then you can record your question. Surprise, surprise by following the details in the show notes. I'm going to finish off with the Ask Marianne Anything jingle and then you will be able to listen to the podcast jingle I will look forward to catching up with you very soon take care and stay kind to you bye I wish you all the most to ask her anything.
继续查看信息，购买《临床心理学家集体》一书（希望在十月出版），或者如果你有有趣的故事要讲，我们仍在接受投稿，投稿详情包含在节目说明中。好了，非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分并收听节目。别忘了，如果你有任何问题想在播客即将到来的“Ask Marianne Anything”特别环节中问我，那么你可以录下你的问题。惊喜，惊喜，按照节目说明中的详细信息操作即可。我将以“Ask Marianne Anything”的叮当声结束，然后你就可以听到播客的叮当声了。我期待很快与你再次交流，保重，对自己好一点，再见。我祝愿你们所有人都能问她任何问题。
Questions and answers. Questions and answers. Questions and answers with Dr. Mary Trent. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become
问答环节。问答环节。与Marianne Trent博士的问答环节。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是Marianne Trent博士的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我叫Jana，是一名实习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为
a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
临床心理学家的内容真的很有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有完美的途径可以成为一名心理学家，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。